to be relevant in today's business
culture if you're not continuously
learning you're actually rapidly falling
behind society is just moving too fast
like technology is just moving too fast
what does it take to stand out online
what steps do you need to take
personally to be at your best in the
content you're creating the communities
that you're stewarding and the courses
and products that you are creating i'm
excited because in today's episode we're
jumping into part two of the at your
best series this is pulling back the
curtain about what we're doing here at
think media as a team focused on a
mission to be at our best for you this
year my name is heather torres and i'm
the host of the think media podcast the
number one podcast to help you grow your
influence on youtube and then turn that
influence into a high impact and a high
income online business and in today's
episode like i said we are peeling back
the curtain we're bringing you on the
inside of our most recent leadership
retreat it sounds crazy to think that
we're at a level now at think media
where we're flying people in to las
vegas to gather so that we can be all on
the same foot as we head into the new
year we are now in that new year and we
wanted to share with you a session from
that leadership retreat we shared the
first part of that last week and we're
diving into part two and then later on
this year we will deliver three and four
to you but in this episode we're going
to be diving into a new commitment last
week we went over the commitment to
wellness because we want to be at our
best as we go into this year
and this week we're heading into the
commitment to excellence here at think
media we want to be at the top of our
game for all of the things that we are
doing from the content we're creating to
the courses we're putting out to the
conferences that we are hosting so being
committed to excellence is one of the
things we are focused on this year let's
dive into today's future content and
we'll discuss it afterwards
[Music]
but the second area
that we are committed to being at our
best in in 2022
is a commitment
to excellence
a commitment to excellence we have a
commitment to wellness and a commitment
to
excellence i really believe that
excellence is actually the overflow
of wellness that is the overflow
of actually wellness so what would it
look like for you to be at your best in
the specific skill sets
of your role
in 2022
you know we're gonna have some
discussion time after this again and so
that'll be a question to be pondering is
what would it look like
in your specific role
maybe even as you're journaling
what are the skill sets there's the
broad skill set but what are the nuanced
skill sets inside of that that you would
want to improve in
you know i might say public speaking but
then i could probably break public
speaking into 10 or 20 even nuanced
skill sets that i actually want to get
better at storytelling i want to get
better at breath control i want to get
better at
tonation where sometimes we shout and
speak loud and bold and sometimes we
bring people close
with a whisper
we pause
we lower our voice so what are some
skill sets that you would want to uh to
level up in this year
being at our best there's really two
levels of excellence two levels of
excellence to think about level one
excellence and i learned this from omar
el taquori is that excellence is doing
the best you can with what you have
excellence is doing this the first level
doing the best you can with what you
have see excellence i think would be a
scary word because it goes back into
comparison
it goes back into like shoot oh no like
i'm not as good as the other person no
excellence is doing the best you can
with what you have in fact perfection is
not even attainable
um
perfection is
a lot of times the reason people
perfectionism is toxic
because perfection is an unreachable
target even vince lombardi said this
perfection is not attainable but if we
chase perfection we can catch excellence
just this pursuit of being better that
moves us towards excellence perfection
is out of reach but excellence is just
doing the best we have it's chasing that
level up you know it's not about our
resources it's about our resourcefulness
it's about just doing the best we have
with what we have today right in our in
our current circumstance and this makes
me think about just the think media
story i mean again if you would have
compared
shawn's early videos with the videos
that nolan and omar are publishing
today
you would have crushed young sean
it's freaking crazy if you would have
compared omar's videos in 2022 you if
you go back just a year it's actually
like dude what was happening
like it there's there's
but it's not it's not perfectionism it's
the pursuit of excellence it's chasing
after that level up and and i think we
already embody this but more so in 2022
we're asking how can we be at our best
to continue to level up because um that
has been the story of think media we
have not had resources in every season
we've had to we've had to be faithful
with what we have
we now have 18 people and think about
we're living in the answer to other
people's prayers so we have to be humble
and grateful but at the same time we're
also like shoot we're still missing or
or there's still areas that we could
grow in and so the content has evolved
at think media um and also haven't our
systems evolved but do our systems still
need work
yes yeah
i mean it's it's that
excellence is not just uh it's not just
in graphic design or it's not just in
our web pages right it's even in
excellence in terms of how we
communicate with each other our internal
systems which is doing the best with
what we have today at one point uh we
didn't have monday boards at all at one
point we didn't have monday right uh but
we want to continue to level up but
level two because there's a second level
of of excellence
and excellence level two is the
relentless
pursuit
of mastery
at our best starts with being at our
best and with our personal record at our
best starts with doing the best with
what we have but make no mistake
we are in business
and no one in business is is going to be
staying up at night just thinking like
oh i don't want to hurt think media's
feelings they don't care about our
feelings our competitors right are not
thinking uh staying up at night and just
thinking like oh i want to play soft
there's something about if we're going
to stay on the cutting edge right we
have to have a relentless pursuit of
mastery
when a new industry starts it's about
who's first
but when it matures it's about who's
best yeah
thus our insurance is again not the fear
of comparison but it but it is the
absolute disdain for complacency
which is
sustained by the pursuit of mastery
and you know we see this in scripture
proverbs 22 29 says do you see someone
skilled in their work they will serve
before kings they will not serve before
officials of low rank
friends i think that's what we're
experiencing
i want to encourage you and acknowledge
you and as we're at this all team
retreat i want to celebrate that we have
had the privilege of serving before
kings 50 million views across our
channels in the last 365 days our
content and our work is being promoted
because it is excellent but the
challenge of being at our best is a
challenge to not ever settle
is to actually say that the pursuit of
mastery is a lifelong pursuit and if we
remain skilled in our work and leveling
up our skills we will have the
opportunity to serve before kings not
before officials of low rank in daniel 6
3 daniel found him safe found himself in
babylon at the time which was kind of i
think the ruling power in the
influential power and it says this it
says that daniel became distinguished
above all other
presidents and sat traps because of an
excellent spirit that was in him and the
king planned to set him over the whole
kingdom
friends if we embody an excellent
spirit
our future is bright
and i believe that
i know that we've accomplished some
incredible things at think media but i
honestly think the best is yet to come
we are just getting started we've only
scratched the surface but the next level
is unlocked on the other side of an
excellent spirit an excellent spirit is
that culture that just says you know it
is about competing with the person in
the mirror and the company we were
yesterday but i'm going to do the best
with what i have and i'm also going to
have a relentless pursuit of
mastery so excellence is a lifelong
pursuit of mastery not settling or
resting on yesterday's success and this
kind of reminds me of kodak kodak
cameras anyone ever have a kodak camera
anybody anybody here remember who who
here you had film roles you took film
roles to costco right to walmart 2k mart
two walgreens dropped off the film roll
60 minutes come back pick up your roll
of film they have photo stores photo
stores
photo max right
and so uh when i think about
not settling or not getting complacent
it actually reminds me of kodak so kodak
was a technology company
that dominated keyword here dominated
the photo the photography film market
for most of the 20th century but the
company blew its chance to lead the
digital photography
revolution as they were in denial for
too long
steve cesan the kodak engineer
actually invented the first digital
camera in 1975.
they were actually the first to market
with their idea with their creativity
um but here's the quote but it was
filmless photography so the management's
reaction was that's cute but don't tell
anyone about it says saison and the
leaders at kodak failed to see digital
photography as a disruptive technology
a former vice president of cod kodak don
strickland says
we developed the world's first consumer
digital camera but we could not get
approval to launch or sell it because of
fear of the effects on the film market
the management was so focused on the
film's success that they missed the
digital revolution after starting it
kodak filed for bankruptcy in 2012 and
the kodak failure surprised
many
when we talk about excellence it makes
me think of this idea that resting on
yesterday's successes
can cause us to fall short of tomorrow's
demands
one of the biggest vulnerabilities for a
team like us celebrating this year is
we're playing the song all we do is win
we're putting sticky notes up here on on
the uh on king flip and it's true and
we've had a great year but that's our
biggest vulnerability is is settling and
getting comfortable and actually not
continuing a pursuit of excellent
because friend hear me i can say this
about every single person in this room
and everybody watching online on zoom is
that
we you're walking in excellence i want
to acknowledge you in that but this is
this is preaching to the choir
but we have to be committed as the choir
to keep working on our vocal cords
had to like roll with the analogy
okay so how do i commit to excellence
how do i commit the excellence as we
land the plane uh halfway through uh so
how do i commit to excellence two steps
two steps the first one is a commitment
to a beginner and student mindset
a beginner and student mindset
now i learned
this term
called shoshem it's actually a term from
zen buddhism it's called shoshen and
here's the definition
it's having an attitude of openness
eagerness
and lack of preconceptions when studying
a subject
even when studying
at an advanced level
just as a beginner in that subject would
shoshen
it's an attitude of having openness
eagerness and a lack of preconceptions
when studying at when studying a subject
and when studying even at an advanced
level
just as a beginner in that subject
would
let me ask you
in light of all think media success in
light of your personal role success in
light of your skill level
are you still just as hungry as you were
at the beginning
are you still as voracious to learn as
you were
at the beginning
this is such a powerful concept to
actually continue to pursue mastery
we can't give up the beginner and
student mindset
and i have watched we talked in the
first session all about wellness i've
watched businesses get sidelined or
individuals get sidelined and fail
i believe also because they give up this
pursuit they settle in their success
and they they i've seen peers do it i've
seen friends do it i've seen different
people that
they read a lot of books early on they
studied a lot early on they wanted to be
at the conference early on because they
were desperate they needed money they
needed growth they were trying to break
through
once they broke through though ah i
don't know if i need to take notes
anymore once they broke through it's
like ah i know this probably one of the
most dangerous statements we could ever
say is i already know that right oh i
know that
oh i've heard that already yeah or i've
heard that before uh omar and i just
went to a business thing this week just
some random thing that i saw and i was
like hey it's in vegas why not go and
there's panels of people and uh legit
business people that i wanted to learn
from and i took a couple pages of notes
and i don't think i wrote down one thing
that i actually hadn't heard before but
i'll tell you this
almost everything i had i don't haven't
mastered right
so i'm not too good to write down the
notes and i'm like this is good it's
good to be reminded about this it's good
to think about this again and i had a
whole pad of notes when when and i could
have had an attitude if i already know
this or why don't they have me up there
speaking or why don't i you know like
why am i even here and so staying when i
think about shoshen i think about
staying humble staying teachable
and staying hungry to learn and grow
secondly
a commitment how do i commit to
excellence is a commitment commitment to
continuous learning continuous learning
not learning sometimes not learning part
of in a certain season but actually
continuous learning many futurists and
nowists if they're such a word is
actually saying that to be relevant in
today's business culture if you're not
continuously learning you're actually
rapidly falling behind society's just
moving too fast like technology is just
moving too fast
and so
i have a question has learning actually
been lost by most
in today's culture absolutely the idea
of continuous learning
yeah andy says absolutely listen to
these stats 33 of high school graduates
never read another book for the rest of
their lives
3 out of 10.
42 of college graduates never read
another book for the rest of their lives
eighty percent of u.s families did not
buy a book or read a book last year
seventy percent of u.s adults have not
been in a bookstore in the last five
years i bet it's like a hundred percent
because the bookstores were close
57
of new books are not read to completion
and i'll admit i'm guilty of that stat
as well though
i did i completed more books than ever
before this year
and and and of course you know
i actually believe that modern learning
is not it doesn't have to be books but
modern learning
is podcasts modern learning is courses
modern learning is workshops modern
learning is audio books money monitor
learning could be certain types of
youtube videos maybe not
you know slime and dance youtube shorts
but longer form rich educational content
and you know what's crazy is brian tracy
said this he said if you read only one
book per month
per month i'd be 12 books a year that
will put you in the top one percent of
income earners in our society
sean will that put me in the top uh one
percent of top earners at think media it
will
if you read a book that'd be 12 books
next year what would happen if you read
12 books in 2022
on the specific skill set you're trying
to grow in
how lethal would you become friend
there's no lid for you at this company
and if you say listen i i learned this i
implemented this and here's how it
affected revenue
i would like some more money humbly
asking hopefully i would say why
wouldn't i you just correlated this to
generating this much more income let's
let's figure out how that correlates to
how you're being compensated of course
because we want you to win in this
company but for you personally and for
anybody listening to this i think we're
gonna put this on our podcast right like
if you read one book per month that'll
put you in the top one percent of income
earners in our society but watch this
but if you read one book per week
50 books a year because you've got two
weeks of vacation that will make you one
of the best educated smartest and most
capable and highest paid people in your
field
regular reading will transform your life
completely
and so again that could be taking a
course it could be taking it could be
committing and i would say there's
probably a distinction it may not just
be listening to a podcast although
probably the think media podcast because
it really goes deep and it's really rich
but sometimes podcasts are
conversational and entertaining there's
something about investing in an online
course with modules with videos with a
syllabus that actually takes you from
not knowing a skill to learning a skill
that would be the idea here and so
what's crazy though is statistics show a
clear relationship between the average
salary and the number of books someone
reads when they hear that quote the more
you learn the more you earn it actually
is true and statistics show that
and recently you know we got to practice
what we preach because here's what we're
asking our students to do we are asking
our students
we're asking our community members hey
buy video ranking academy hey buy the
youtube made simple course hey buy
buy the book youtube made simple buy
youtube secrets
and if we're player coaches then that
means we got to be living that same
lifestyle yeah that's why i recently
just spent over three thousand dollars
in the last couple weeks on educational
materials
i bought in a thousand dollar advanced
business strategy course from patrick
david by the way
you're you have access to of course our
learning library and things like that
being think but an advanced business
strategy course heather and i are going
to go through a business plan workshop
that starts on the east coast at 8 a.m
so we have to get up at 5 00 a.m so
we'll probably have to get up at 4 a.m
she'll get up at 3am because she's got
an hour drive and we're going to take a
12-hour day because this guy is no joke
to take notes the whole day to learn the
whole day i know that's our lifestyle
but that was another thousand dollars i
just bought a harmon brothers script
writing course that was another 850
dollars when when i bought the upsell as
well and then i just bought a course on
on marketing and sailing and positional
on a black friday special kind of like
ours for 300
we got to be player coaches
and so what does it look like to be at
our best in 2022 it looks like a
commitment to
excellence and the two levels is a
beginner mindset which means we're
humble enough to learn humble enough
to prioritize learning and invest in our
learning and then committed to
continuous learning by also not just
purchasing the book i've fallen into
that trap
but actually reading the book and
actually following through and finishing
the book or at least reading the 40 that
actually matter because the rest is
fluff and sometimes that's true and i
don't even think that's bad great you
got the concept if i get one idea of it
a book for fifteen dollars and i just
read the first chapter that's worth it
yeah if i if i just get the one thing
out of it 15 bucks are you kidding me
you know um
all right and so uh
as we land the plane at think media we
are committed to building a personal and
team culture of excellence not
perfection
but excellence doing the best with what
we have and pursuing lifelong mastery
of our craft it reminds me of what babe
ruth said
yesterday's home runs
don't win today's games
2022 is a new year new challenges new
videos to make
new ads to run new
thumbnails to design i can't even
imagine there's more creativity on
thumbnails but i keep being blown out of
the water
and i think a beginner's mindset
whenever we we take a break we refresh
we commit to wellness
we get refreshed we start realizing wow
there's actually so much vast
opportunity there's so much more to say
there's so much more to teach
and and we can be refreshed for
excellence refusing to settle and
continuing to grow as we commit
to excellence
wow i mean commitment to excellence
really makes us level up ourselves as we
head into this year pairing that with
the commitment to wellness and now the
commitment to excellence we want to be
at our best in everything that we are
doing and i want to encourage you to be
at your best this year as well what do
you need to commit to where do you need
to bring excellence what do you need to
learn so that you can grow in the areas
that are going to level you up i want to
encourage you that if you know that you
want to grow your online business using
the power of video that this year you
need to be at grow with video live
if you've never heard of this before
this is our fifth conference that we've
hosted here at think media and this is
our annual gathering this is our annual
conference bringing all of the best
people in the industry to help you grow
your online business this year one of
our featured speakers is gary vaynerchuk
and he's going to be giving a keynote
during this conference now you can pick
up your general admission or a vip
ticket right now at growethvideolive.com
and if you've never been to a conference
before i cannot wait to see you in
person i know it can be scary to step
out of your comfort zone to go to a new
city to be in a room with people you
don't know but can i tell you that my
life was changed by being in the room i
was one of those people and still am
sometimes when i get scared to be at
these things but pushing outside of my
comfort zone and stepping out and going
after the things that i know are scary
like going to a conference those are the
life-changing moments the friendships
i've gained the people i've networked
with and the knowledge i have gained
from these types of speakers this is
what could be the thing that changes
your year so i encourage you to go to
growethvideolive.com right now and grab
your ticket and bring a friend make this
an adventure
and i'll see you in person in may in las
vegas for grow with video live now i
want to thank all of our think media
community we are growing so fast i
cannot believe how many people now are
listening and subscribing like when i
actually think about it it kind of gives
me some fear and anxiety when i think
that tens of thousands of people are
listening to this podcast but i'm
pushing past the fear and i'm saying
thank you because we are on a mission to
help 10 000 purpose-driven people create
a full-time living doing what they love
through the power of video and making an
impact in the world so i'm so excited
about all of our new subscribers here on
the podcast now if you are listening
over on apple or spotify i want you to
hit that subscribe button right now so
that you get notified every time a new
episode is ready for you to download and
if you're over on youtube hit that red
subscribe button so that you can also
see all of the content that we have on
the channel now our channel is slightly
different than the actual audio podcast
because we're putting up more and more
content on the youtube channel things
like the youtube made simple show that i
host every other week the coffee with
candles show where we bring on people
and answer your questions live and
things like partnering with vid iq and
thinkific where we can do channel
reviews and help you grow things like
your online courses and so much more so
make sure you're subscribed over on
youtube and maybe you'll be featured on
a future episode
today i want to shout out uh one of our
listeners that put a comment on the uh
what do you do when you have an
unsupportive family member episode that
was up on the podcast this is from
michelle michelle says so good one thing
i've learned is that no one else can
make me feel good about myself i have to
take care of my esteem and motivation on
my own well michelle i want you to know
that we are here cheerleading you on
also don't think that you're in this
game alone we are here as a team
committed to your learning to your
growth and committed to your success as
well so thank you for being a part of
our community michelle and leaving that
comment and i hope michelle that i get
to see you in person in may at grow with
video live well thank you so much for
being a part of what we're doing here at
think media we have so many exciting
episodes coming up in the next few weeks
and months as we lead into
such a great year but i want to bring
you back to what is your next action
step what do you need to do next to
commit yourself to excellence i think
it's so important that we rally around
the theme of at your best and i can't
wait to see what you do this year on
youtube thank you so much for watching
or listening and i'll catch you in a
future episode
you